[Musica]
[Applauso]
sostenibilità vuol dire anche capacità
di adattamento ai cambiamenti che il
nostro territorio Si trova a dover
affrontare
Modena cambiamento climatico ma siamo
davvero sicuri che stia avvenendo Oggi è
il 13 maggio 2023 e presso
l'osservatorio Geofisico situato nel
Torrione di Levante del Palazzo Ducale
di Modena rileviamo una temperatura di
17 gradi e mezzo in balconata storica
nostro punto di riferimento per le
misure è tanto è poco
Modena 13 maggio
1861 presso il Regio osservatorio voluto
dal Duca Francesco IV d'Este misuriamo
oggi 18 gradi nella stessa balconata la
temperatura minima di oggi è stata di 15
gradi e mezzo mentre la massima è stata
di 20 gradi e mezzo ma quindi oggi 2023
è più freddo rispetto a tanti anni fa
Ma quindi il clima di Modena sta davvero
cambiando
scopriamoli insieme in un viaggio tra
Passato presente e futuro possibile
grazie ai dati che l'osservatorio
Geofisico raccoglie Modena da quasi 200
anni
Esatto perché dal 1861 che nella
balconata che vedete alle nostre spalle
si fanno delle misure di parametri
meteorologici Ma che cosa misuravamo
cosa misuriamo E cosa misureremo in
osservatorio per capire la presenza e
l'entità del cambiamento
certo sicuramente andiamo a misurare i
valori massimi di temperatura i
cosiddetti picchi ma quelli ci sono
sempre stati ad esempio nel 1873
nell'estate si misurò un valore record
di 36 gradi e 4 questo record è stato
battuto varie volte negli anni fino ad
arrivare al 1983 anno in cui è stato
registrato il più alto valore di
temperatura di tutta la serie 38 gradi e
mezzo ma non sono le temperature massime
che ci fanno capire l'entità del
cambiamento sono le temperature medie e
se quindi noi riprendiamo l'anno del
Picco il 1983 vediamo che la media di
quell'estate e per estate intendo
l'estate meteorologica i mesi di giugno
luglio e agosto è stata pari a soli 24
gradi e 8 e perché vi dico soli perché
se andiamo un pochino più avanti dopo
gli anni 2000 i numeri cambiano
drasticamente l'estate
2003 è stata la più calda di sempre vi
ricordate tutti l'estate 2003 Beh se non
la ricordate proprio bene ricorderete
senza dubbio l'estate 2022 quella scorsa
Ecco lì abbiamo sfiorato il record con
una temperatura media di 27 gradi e
mezzo
quindi stati sempre più calde che cosa
invece mi puoi dire degli inverni
passati gli inverni erano molto freddi
come ormai non siamo più abituati a
viverne in osservatorio ad esempio nel
1864 si misuravano temperature minime di
meno 12 meno 13 gradi molto
frequentemente E se anche qui vogliamo
parlare di temperature medie giustamente
la media invernale in quell'anno fu di
tre gradi Celsius molto diversa
dall'inverno appena passato che ha visto
una temperatura media invernale di 7
gradi e mezzo e sempre riguardo agli
inverni freddi eccetera in osservatori
abbiamo trovato rovistando tra le carte
degli articoli molto particolari
Guardate questo Brescia 14 febbraio
1929 anche le uova che commercianti di
città tenevano di scorta sono gelate e
siccome è mancato il rifornimento dalla
campagna oggi non si trovavano più uova
in tutta la città
ma non solo abbiamo trovato altre
curiosità sapete anche all'epoca
nell'Ottocento sui giornali c'erano la
pubblicità guardate questa parla di un
unguento particolarmente miracoloso tale
da riuscire a fare guarire dai geloni
nell'arco di soli 4 giorni ma non solo
abbiamo letto della laguna di Venezia
completamente gelata con i vaporetto
trasformati navi e rompighiaccio per
aprirsi un varco lungo i canali tutto
molto diverso dall'inverno Appena
concluso dove il valore minimo che
abbiamo misurato in osservatorio è stato
di pari di meno 0,6 gradi e so che
qualcuno di voi magari in campagna avrà
misurato valori anche più bassi ma il
nostro riferimento per il clima il
nostro volume di aria rappresentativo è
proprio nella balconata
Ma andiamo adesso nel presente con uno
sguardo nel passato per capire cosa è
cambiato in tutti questi anni e lo
facciamo tramite un grafico Quello alle
nostre spalle si chiamano Warning
Stripes strisce del clima ogni striscia
rappresenta la temperatura media di
quell'anno e viene calcolata e viene
colorata con colori freddi o colori
caldi a seconda dell'entità della
anomalia in colori freddi in blu
anomalie negative I colori rossi per
anomalie positive come potete vedere già
dagli anni 90 c'è stato un susseguirsi
continuo di anni più caldi culminato
prima nel 2014 e poi nel 2022 l'anno più
caldo dà inizio osservazioni meteo a
Modena mandiamo adesso più nel dettaglio
Dobbiamo capire la portata e gli effetti
che il cambiamento climatico anche a
livello locale possono avere su di noi e
lo facciamo con due esempi il primo le
notti tropicali quelle notti in cui la
temperatura minima non perde mai sotto i
20 gradi centigradi Ecco come vedete dal
grafico alle nostre spalle il numero di
queste notti è notevolmente aumentato
negli ultimi anni e se andiamo
all'opposto e prendiamo le gelate cioè
quei giorni in cui la temperatura minima
sta al di sotto degli zero gradi
centigradi Ecco la tendenza è
esattamente all'opposto questi giorni
sono calati drasticamente Quindi
rispetto a un passato che abbiamo appena
visto insieme e ha un presente che
viviamo qui noi tutti i giorni che cosa
ci aspetta per il futuro
Beh i numeri sono chiari abbiamo
calcolato i Trend le tendenze prendendo
a riferimento il trentennio
1991-2020 E se continuiamo così si parla
in 100 anni di un aumento di temperatura
fino a 8 gradi centigradi Questo vuol
dire che nel 2070 potremmo trovarci e
stati con temperature massime di 44 45
gradi e connotate estive di 24-25 gradi
di temperatura
quindi temperature più elevate superfici
più calde mari più caldi Tutto questo a
che cosa porta porta anche ad avere più
energia a disposizione per i temporali
Adesso vi dico una data e vediamo chi se
la ricorda 22 giugno 2019 qualcuno la
ricorda
se c'è un assicuratore in sala se la
ricorda Certamente perché ha dovuto
pagare i danni a mezza Modena per una
grandinata a dir poco eccezionale
ma non solo grandinate dobbiamo parlare
più In generale gli eventi estremi
perché sono l'esempio tangibile del
cambiamento climatico in corso mi
vengono in mente recenti tornado ne
abbiamo avuti due nella primavera del
2013 e poi del 2014 e ancora più
recentemente Nel febbraio del 2021 sono
stati fenomeni localizzati ma
estremamente violenti con 20 fino a 260
km all'ora tali da scoperchiare i tetti
degli edifici da spezzare grossi alberi
e lanciare piccoli oggetti in aria come
missili capite bene che procedendo di
questo passo da Motor Valley a tornado
Valley è davvero un attimo
ma il cambiamento climatico lo
percepiamo anche sulla nostra pelle
osservando un clima che cambia Ti
ricordi dei bambini che sono venuti a
trovarci in osservatorio abbiamo chiesto
loro se gli piaceva la neve naturalmente
ci hanno risposto di sì ma ci siamo resi
conto che nelle loro minchia di mancava
il ricordo di una Modena innevata E
questo perché ormai la neve manca da
Modena da parecchio tempo l'ultima
nevicata risale al 13 febbraio 2021 ma
nell'occasione fu di soli un centimetro
l'ultima nevicata con la N maiuscola
risale al 5 6 Febbraio 2015
nell'occasioneta caddero 30 cm causarono
diverse disagi io lo ricordo bene perché
era il giorno prima del mio matrimonio
In conclusione il cambiamento climatico
è reale ed è reale anche qui a Modena ma
noi cosa possiamo fare che cosa dobbiamo
fare i bambini che erano venuti in
osservatorio avevano le idee molto
chiare e ci hanno proposto delle
soluzioni dalle più semplici andare in
giro in bicicletta spegnere sempre la
luce a più complesse usare un'auto
elettrica piantare tanti alberi e
qualcuno ha ipotizzato anche il mangiare
meno carne azioni piccole azioni grandi
mazioni concrete di Chissà che con le
azioni Si può cambiare qualcosa ma noi
siamo pronti a cambiare
il clima di domani sarà sicuramente
diverso da quello del giorno d'oggi il
quanto sarà diverso sarà funzione delle
nostre azioni e delle decisioni di chi
ci governa importanti Anzi
importantissime saranno le azioni di
mitigazione cioè tutte quelle azioni
volte diminuire la concentrazione di Gas
clima alteranti come la CO2 però abbiamo
visto il cambiamento climatico Ormai in
corso Dobbiamo conviverci e dobbiamo
adattarci cambiando anche le nostre
abitudini ma voi ma noi che rapporto
abbiamo con le abitudini proviamo a
scoprirlo insieme con un esperimento
viene proposto da uno scienziato Dennis
middles che anche autore del libro Il
limite dello sviluppo facciamolo insieme
allora vi chiedo di incrociare le
braccia davanti a voi di mettervi a
braccia conserte per favore
Perfetto Adesso guardate in basso e
guardate Qual è il polso che avete messo
sopra Se il polso destro o il polso
sinistro sciogliete le braccia che ha
messo sopra il polso destro sulla mano o
quasi tutte Giù le mani chi ha messo
sopra il polso sinistro
Perfetto Adesso incrociate le braccia al
contrario con l'altro polso sopra
Accidenti È più complesso del previsto
Scegliete pure le braccia con questo
piccolo gioco Notiamo tre cose che
possiamo trasferire anche alla nostra
capacità di adattarci uno cambiare le
nostre abitudini è possibile 2 però
dobbiamo rifletterci e specie all'inizio
faremo degli errori
tre cambiare può essere scomodo
soprattutto all'inizio ma si creano
nuove abitudini questa volta sostenibili
[Applauso]